[Musik]
wer hört wen noch zu warum sind so viele
wütend schon in Familien manchmal
schreien wir auch ne
manchmal lachen wir manchmal trennen wir
uns in Wut für die Christiane ist die
Mutter eine grüne chris ist der Sohn und
in der AFD politisch kann man gerade
kaum weiter entfernt sein in Deutschland
wir halten die beiden das aus sie
streiten in unserer filterblase
ist halt die Grünen definitiv für eine
totalitäre in Teilen verstehe lass mich
bitte
propagieren die Welt Rettung also
Vergleich grüne nationalsozial wirklich
von euch vor allen Dingen ich habe noch
nie zu dir gesagt nein
Stimmung Meinung Fakten alles prasselt
auf uns ein und füllt unsere Filter
Blasen
man lernt doch nicht sprechen und die
Schnauze zu halten wenn es drauf ankommt
die Probleme die die Leute bewegen die
werden von den meisten Politik nicht
angenommen und für mich zählt
Podest die Politik Ärger
angestaute Wut
Land ist im Meinungskampf
die Demokratie zeigt es gibt freihälter
aber wir können lauter reden schönen Tag
[Musik]
ich bin dabei bis zu dabei sind wir
dabei uns zu verlieren
Deutschland so unversöhnlich gehört auf
die Couch der Vater und die Tochter aus
dem Osten der Republik und Mutter und
Sohn aus dem Westen sie reden
ungeschminkt über Konflikte
Überzeugungen
zwei Familien stellvertreten für die
Pole in unserer Gesellschaft für Risse
im Land diese Reise durch Filtern Blasen
soll helfen die Stimmung in der
Krisenzeit besser zu verstehen wo die
politische Mitte so schwer zu finden ist
ja im Prinzip hat jeder seine Nische
glaube ich nur sich zu Hause fühlt sei
es jetzt digital oder auch in der
Realität
wir alle bewegen uns in filterblasen
diese hier steht bei einer Werbeagentur
in Hamburg für jedes Nutzerprofil spuckt
die Bubble gezielt Nachrichten Posts und
Tweets der letzten 24 Stunden aus
filtert was Menschen die ähnlich denken
im Netz anspricht Heiko braun wählt aus
Protest die AFD mein Name ist Heiko
braun Baujahr 1965
komme aus Tal in Thüringen und ich bin
der Meinung dass in diesem Land
politisch einiges passieren muss damit
die Demokratie gerettet wird und die
miteinander wieder besser umgehen können
als Protest würde mich eher Richtung SPD
tendenziell sehen krasser Gegensatz ja
aber ich würde mich eher Richtung
Sozialdemokratie sehen
weil ich bin Arbeiterkind und ich habe
auch die Hoffnung dass die SPD das
Bruder rumreißen könnte wenn sie denn
nicht immer gegen die AFD kämpfen würde
Rebecca braun sieht nicht alles wie ihr
Vater sie schenkt gar keiner Partei mehr
Vertrauen macht ihren Stimmzettel
ungültig
ich bin Rebecca Braun geboren 1990 in
Thüringen lebe auch bis heute dort in
der Nähe von Eisenach politisch fühle
ich mich gerade überhaupt nicht
vertreten würde mich selber eher als
neutral in der Mitte einordnen Chris
schnapperts und seine Mutter klar wo sie
stehen also 65 plus
grüne
ich bin Christiane von Gierke
1980 bin ich in den Bundesvorstand der
Grünen gewählt worden und wir leben in
einer Familie in der sehr bunt politisch
zugeht ich bin Chris schnappert ich bin
der Sohn ich bin Pressesprecher der AFD
Landtagsfraktion in NRW und ich würde
sagen von der Position her normal also
in der Mitte der Partei
die politische bunte Familie zum 75
Geburtstag trifft sie aufeinander ich
freue mich wirklich uns noch mal zu
sagen dass ihr alle da seid nicht alle
eine Freundin hat abgesagt weil sie
nicht zusammen mit Christiane von girkes
Sohn dem afd-funktionär feiern will
du warst ja bei den 68ern aktiv und hast
die Grünen mit gegründet
aber du hast mich das selbstständige
Denken gelehrt ich bin kein linkes
Schneeflöckchen ich bin ein braver
deutsch-nationaliberaler Hedonist mein
er empfinden mein Standesbewusstsein
meine Wehrhaftigkeit mein chorgeist
meine Sturheit und ganz wichtig mein
Familiensinn habe ich von dir ich glaube
heute wird jemand wie ich als toxischer
weißer Mann bezeichnet also ich habe
auch gute Freunde verloren ja oder auch
Beziehungen sind nicht zustande gekommen
oder in die Brüche gegangen also mit
Frauen wegen meiner Arbeit vor 40 Jahren
war die Mutter grüne Rebellen heute
lehnt sich der konservative Sohn gegen
ihre Ideale auf er will das Land mit der
AFD nach rechts rücken meine beste
Freundin kam nicht weil ihr Mann
gesagt hat mich nicht mit einem AFD an
den Tisch
und das ist aber eine sehr konservative
Familie als ich sie kennenlernte waren
sie richtig schwarze cdu-ler und ich war
ja grüne und das hat mir nichts
ausgemacht und das finde ich ganz
schlimm diese Spaltung der Gesellschaft
in eine die eine richtige und die eine
falsche Meinung
[Applaus]
ich hoffe ich konnte ausdrücken vielen
Dank
eine Familie mit Wurzeln im alten
Westdeutschland politische Debatten
wurden offen am Küchentisch ausgefochten
auch zwischen Bruder und Schwester Heike
noch eine grüne wir sind auf den auf dem
jeweils anderen auf der anderen Seite
des politischen Spektrums und immer
schon gewesen
von
euch
seidagen quasi seit ich aktiv geworden
bin eigentlich da ja aber du warst schon
als du ein Kind warst immer immer ganz
anders du warst immer wehrhaft und du
hast immer gesagt ich bin Mann und man
muss sich wehren und ich habe immer
gesagt naja man muss ja verstehen was
der andere sagt und versuchen den
gegenüber oder das Gegenüber zu
verstehen gibt dann auch Streites knallt
dann auch statt auch teilweise heftig
geknallt und auch mal jemanden
aufgestanden ist und gegangen ist
aber das hat nie lange eigentlich
angehalten mir tut es auch weh dass du
so so weit politisch von mir entfernt
bist dass du dass du Dinge vertritt die
ich zutiefst ablehne
ja das ist eigentlich das ist ganz ganz
traurig und ihr wir sind ja auch eure
lieblingsregler
ist die AFD in der Demokratische Partei
definitiv
dabei das ist da bin ich schon in
Teilbereichen kritisch wo wir uns auch
manchmal einig sind dass ich sage ich
lehne das zutiefst ab was du vertrittst
aber ich finde es muss Raum sein dass
Leute wie du sich äußern können also es
gibt vieles was meine Schwester sagt die
ich auch wohl was ich ganz oft sage wir
haben tolles Verhältnis liebe sie sehr
aber wo ich mehr teilweise denke die
kann nur sie sowas vertreten die die
kann sie sowas meinen in den Kampf das
ist ja manchmal den wir in der Familie
führen ist ja eigentlich Kampf gegen den
man in der Gesellschaft führen muss und
wenn ich
habe ich immer gedacht wenn ich da
kapituliere dann
will man dann hin mit dieser
Gesellschaft die Nation des Volk ist für
mich einfach nur eine erweiterte Familie
im Endeffekt also jetzt natürlich nicht
so eine enge Bindung aber man hat eine
ähnliche Kultur man hat die gleiche
Sprache man hat eine gleiche Geschichte
unterschiedlich ja meiner Familie das
war ja auch meine Schuld
ist ja aber trotzdem ist für mich ähm
[Musik]
hat geotismus schon sehr wichtig man
muss auch gucken dass man Leute wie
Chris möglichst im noch demokratischen
Bereich hält und ja doch ich bin
demokratisch
respektiere die Mehrheiten
verboten
unterhält sie das Gleiche denken wie du
dann ist die Gefahr dass du immer weiter
in die rechte Ecke abdriftest erstmal
rechte Ecke ist immer noch demokratisch
genauso wie die linke Ecke demokratische
wo es problematisch wird ist wenn es ins
Extreme oder radikale gibt weiß dass wir
da unterschiedliche Definition haben und
manches was
ich nicht so ich sehe z.B vieles ich
habe das eine Weile so genossen dieser
ganze alte CDU Omi was ich von früher
kannte aus meiner Jugend dieses ganze
verkrustete oh war das war das dieses ah
es war schrecklich und es waren Punkte
da dachte ich ist das toll wir sind
jetzt ein offenes Land geworden und es
ist alles so viel dieser ganze Mief ist
weg na dann kam die AFD
und die anhaltende krisenflut schwemmt
die AFD nach oben
Björn Corona als Leute zu Hause
eingesperrt wurden als den Bürgern ihre
Grundrechte entzogen wird Corona war
eine völlig neue Situation in der Welt
und das wird das richtige
bedroht von diesem Virus und wir mussten
jetzt erstmal wir mussten jetzt erstmal
Wege finden wie können wir dieses Virus
bekämpfen ne das ist doch und das ist
doch auch Aufgabe der Politik gerade
diese drei Themen Ukraine Krieg
Migration Corona
da ist man auch eigentlich komplett dem
falschen Weg gegangen auch die Meinung
aus anderen zu akzeptieren dann ist der
andere einfach ganz schnell abgestempelt
worden wenn sie Migration ist er
rechtsradikal so Ukraine Krieg hat das
nicht verstanden was läuft und bei
Corona sagt
Querdenker und fügt sich nicht das ist
massiv gelaufen gerade Corona das sind
Maßnahmen gemacht worden die massiv in
die Privatsphäre eingegriffen worden
Migration nichts dagegen ich habe auch
nichts gegen Ausländer
die Arbeiten dann ihr steuern die
integrieren sich und wenn sie sich nicht
anpassen müssen Maßnahmen folgen und das
Scheitern auch der Rechtsstaat momentan
gerade was Migration angeht was ist
meine Erfahrungs background mein ganz
persönlicher nicht der den ich über das
Internet vermittelt bekomme und ich für
mich muss zum Beispiel sagen mit denen
Menschen die aus dem Ausland nach
Deutschland kommen seien sie jetzt
Studenten oder auch wenn man Leute an
der Arbeit oder an der Tankstelle oder
weiß ich nicht wo trifft die dann
vielleicht arbeiten ich habe bislang
keine schlechten Erfahrungen gemacht
meine Erfahrung ist keine negative es
tut mir auch leid ich bin ich habe auch
nichts gegen diese Leute die aus der
subse Sahara oder aus arabischen Staaten
oder so probieren nach Deutschland zu
kommen das würde ich an deren Stelle
wahrscheinlich ganz genauso machen ja
weil das Leben hier auch mit Sozialhilfe
deutlich besser ist als in ihren
Regionen das wäre ich Ihnen nicht vor
aber ich werfe es dem Start vor dass er
tut es kann jeder kommen es kann immer
aufgenommen werden es ist sehr schwierig
also die Gesellschaft ist in dieser
Frage ja außerordentlich gespalten wie
man ja auch an euren Umfrageergebnissen
sieht ich denke selber auch dass das
nicht so weitergehen kann also unsere
ganze Mittelschicht trägt ja
letztendlich diesen Start da hast du
schon Recht
und die kann man nicht Schröpfen bis es
eben gar nicht mehr geht das sehe ich
auch so auf der anderen Seite muss man
natürlich auch humanitär sein ja man
muss natürlich Leute aufnehmen wie jetzt
die Ukraine die Woche gar nicht drüber
das ist völlig egal alles andere muss
man natürlich möglichst auch human
gestalten ne wenn die Leute
zurückgeführt werden dass ihnen da z.B
auch nichts passiert
und vergewaltigt ist mir das egal ob ihm
die Todesstrafe in seinem Heimatland der
hat das Gast
aber das lassen
total extreme Geschichten das ist doch
nicht die Mehrheit der Leute Leute
kleine
minderjährigen ist die Anzahl an den
Gewaltverbrechen die haben da deutlich
überrepräsentiert
polarisieren das hilft der AFD auch bei
Wahlen gegen den CDU-Kandidaten und alle
anderen Parteien gewinnt sie ihr erstes
Amt in Deutschland stellt den Landrat in
Sonneberg
es zeigt sich auch was es bringt
Brandmauern aufzubauen die Grünen
anzustreichen was machen die Bürger
gerade hier in Thüringen Sachsen in
Ostdeutschland im Mitteldeutschland die
stellen einen Ausreiseantrag zu AFD und
das ist hier heute
die AFD ist der Propaganda die nutzen
richtig Schwächen der anderen massiv aus
aber selbst die Parteien untereinander
aus jeder versucht den anderen schlecht
zu reden anstatt miteinander zu reden
und das Gute gemeinsam zu machen wird
schlecht geredet
Protestwähler Heiko braun auf seiner
täglichen pendeltour zwischen Thüringen
und Hessen seit 30 Jahren arbeitet der
Servicetechniker in Eschwege mit seiner
Stimme für die AFD will er die anderen
Parteien aufrütteln will auch mehr
Anerkennung für das was Ostdeutschland
mitbringt hier im Betrieb wird das
geschätzt
was neues vom Kunden
Gefahren
läuft die Firma auch und was meinen die
Kollegen uns geht's schon recht gut und
wenn man nicht meckert passiert gar
nichts
aber man muss ja irgendwann sagen ja ich
will auch was bewegen
und ja das ist momentan schwieriger
geworden Heiko braun dem Mann der jetzt
afd-wählt statt SPD geht es auch um
seine Lebensleistung um das was er
mitbringt ins geeinte Deutschland seit
20 Jahren wird er immer wieder in den
Betriebsrat gewählt also war ich selber
erstaunt was für Vertrauen
und ich glaube das ist nicht wirklich
kleiner geworden auf einen anderen
Kalender ich habe noch mehr Kalender das
ist ja nicht wie warm Leute
denn wir gerne meinen Kollegen das Essen
vor Corona habe ich immer aufmerksam
geworden
man muss sie einfach akzeptieren diese
Sicherheit die man hatte die war 1990
Jahre komplett zerstört das was man
nicht in ausreichende Maß gefördert hat
ist dass man den Leuten und in der
ehemaligen DDR das Wissen oder die
Fähigkeiten an die Hand gegeben hat sich
selber einzubringen
schon das für mich gefühlt
der Osten immer noch anders behandelt
wird wieder Westen die Anpassung Ostern
West hat wie damals versprochen von
Herrn Kohl nicht funktioniert blühende
Landschaften machen wir also im Osten
tatsächlich Blitz im Osten hier oder
damals nämlich bei den abgerissenen
Fabriken wo mittlerweile Gras drüber
wächst und Bäume wachsen wir haben der
Boutique damals vertraut
blühende Landschaften also das ist schon
eine glatte Lüge gewesen ne sind ja
ganze Betriebe die nicht
notwendigerweise abgebaut werden mussten
verscherbelt worden und es sind riesige
Gewinne gemacht worden und das ist
natürlich sind die Ostdeutschen sauer
und benachteiligt finde ich und was
politisch ist ist halt momentan auch das
Problem
dass der Osten oftmals abgestempelt wird
gerade AFD ist ja stark im Osten und da
wird wenn die Ostdeutschen nicht oftmals
genau diese Schublade gezogen
dieser Aussage ja der Osten geht montags
auf die Straße der Osten wird AFD der
Osten ist ein braunes der Osten hat
nichts geleistet der verträgt die Augen
weil es gibt sicherlich Regionen und
einzelne Personen die extrem
mit ihrem Frust umgehen ich kann es
eigentlich nicht mehr hören dass man
ständig sagt der Osten der Osten der
Osten der Scheiße der ist schlecht weil
genau das ist er nicht
es gibt so viele gute Menschen tolle
Menschen mittlerweile auch viele
Unternehmen
die Unis sind gut besucht eben gerade
auch von Leuten aus dem Westen weil die
Uni ist einfach unglaublich gut sind was
ich da gehört habe Dunkeldeutschland
Demokratie fern und so weiter und so
fort also sehr von oben herab gerade
häufig aus dem Westen und ich glaube
wenn man Leute beschimpft dann sagen ja
auch irgendwann gut jetzt erst recht ich
glaube das ist eine Grundvoraussetzung
warum wir in Ostdeutschland jetzt
aktuell stärkste Partei sind was bietet
die AFD den Menschen in Ostdeutschland
sie bietet Ihnen glaube ich eine Idee
wie Deutschland sein könnte und wie es
glaube ich viele Ostdeutsche auch gerne
hätten
ja
quasi in Deutschland jetzt nicht nur
aufbruchzeit Bände sondern eigentlich in
den 80er 90er Jahren mit einer gewissen
wirtschaftlichen Sicherheit mit einer
guten Infrastruktur mit einer hohen
inneren Sicherheit
naja aber da muss ich mal sagen also
1890er Jahre also wir leben in einer
ganz anderen Welt man kann doch das Rad
nicht zurücknehmen
es geht da eher um um Werte das
werte-system in unserer Demokratie
scheint gerade im Streit unterzugehen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen hallo
erstmal Ruhe hier die Kollegen müssen
noch zur Abstimmung also es ist kein
Grund sich jetzt aufzuregen
die Nerven liegen hier scheinbar blank
kurz vor der Sommerpause als bräuchte
das Land nicht gerade jetzt Zuversicht
und Kompass auch für die nächste
Generation
Rebecca braun Blechkuchen bei der
Ausstellungseröffnung geboren im Jahr
der Wiedervereinigung jongliert sie als
Leiterin eines Heimatmuseums im
thüringischen Camburg mit knappen
Mitteln in der Freizeit lebt sie Cosplay
Verkleidungen wie die Figuren aus Manga
Comics und Videospielen anders sein
anders sein lassen
was die Zukunft bringt weiß ich nicht
und aktuell ist es glaube ich auch so
dass man fast gar nicht mehr irgendwie
groß Pläne machen kann einfach weil die
Situation das nicht hergibt gerade eben
für die jungen Leute die Situation ja
auch nicht hergibt sei es finanziell sei
es eben dann so Dinge wie Corona zum
Beispiel die dann einfach plötzlich dazu
kommen ich bin
da tatsächlich so dass ich sage ich
liebe mir und jetzt ich habe generell
glaube ich so einen anderen Weg gewählt
als meine Eltern also
sicherlich hat es immer ein bisschen
auch was damit zu tun dass man sich von
seinen Eltern ja irgendwo auch
unterscheiden möchte abgrenzen möchte
für mich stand eigentlich relativ
schnell fest dass das was meine Eltern
machen also wirklich arbeiten gehen in
der Fabrik gehen jeden Tag dass das
nicht das ist mit dem ich mich wohl
fühle ja ich wollte einfach studieren
und für mich wäre Technik nicht in Frage
gekommen und im Büro sitzen
die Richtung wo man gut und regelmäßig
Geld verdienen kann und die
Studienwünsche waren halt anders
gelagert
das ging los mit
Tierarzt
aber dann muss man gegen eine
Schauspieler da habe ich da abgeschaltet
muss ich ehrlich sagen habe ich
abgeschaltet das ist für mich brotlose
Kunst jetzt im Nachhinein muss ich mich
oder immer dafür entschuldigen
oh du hast deine Leistung geschafft bin
froh uns macht dir Spaß das macht mir
total Spaß Eltern und Kinder auch immer
ein Streit um den richtigen Weg Eltern
prägen aber die Wahl auch politisch
treffen Kinder am Ende selbst das müssen
Familien aushalten man fragt sich
natürlich was hast Du falsch gemacht
oder hast du irgendwas falsch gemacht
kann man denn das als Eltern überhaupt
letztendlich steuern die haben sehr viel
politisch diskutiert vielleicht waren
wir auch zu manchmal zu regite habe ich
mir überlegt vielleicht haben wir unsere
Meinung den Kindern doch zu sehr
übergestülpt ja
das kann durchaus sein oder das ist
sicher auch so und dass die erste
Entwicklung sicherlich die war sich
abzugrenzen gegen die Eltern also aus
Protest
gut das war nicht im Grünen das war von
der Merkel haben sagst du eigentlich
Fräulein Merkel Frau Merkel ja
Schwierigkeiten mit dieser Dame habe
ich muss mir unglaublich viel anhören
was überhaupt nicht meine Meinung ist
dass ich vielleicht auch teilweise für
dumm halten wie teilweise wahrscheinlich
auch Leute über das was ich sage ähnlich
denken aber man muss es aushalten man
muss es ertragen man muss ja Duden das
ist tolerant willkommen in meiner feste
Farbe
aus der federblase kommt man eigentlich
raus indem man zunächst mal bei sich
selber anfängt ja wirklich nicht
pauschalisieren abstempeln und im
Gespräch auch respektvoll mit der
Meinung des anderen umgehen aber die
Menschen nicht mitnimmt
von oben herab das funktioniert nicht
[Musik]